jaina got mad
jada says she's not coming
protesting i'm like is she on the tv
show
jade is going boycott the austin jada
boycott in the oscars is like me
boycotting rihanna's panties
i wasn't invited
jaina i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait
to see it all right
[Applause]
oh
richard
[Laughter]
oh wow
wow
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
and secondly and even more important is
um your whole career as a comedian is
about making fun of pretentious
high-minded
self-congratulatory bs events like this
one
[Music]
the whole feeling in this room of
reverence and honoring is the exact
opposite of everything i have wanted my
life to be about
i i i really don't want to be up here
i want to be in the back over there
somewhere over there saying something
funny to somebody about what a croc this
whole thing is
wow dude
yeah it was a g.i james keep my wife's
name out
i'm going to okay
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
i don't know where if i'd be standing
here today if it wasn't for my shop
teacher mr no fingers
two big thumbs up to you buddy
and an extra
special tip of the hat to my art teacher
miss never wore a bra
you my lady made learning fun again
uh and i just want to say
this movie was a life-changing
experience i saw some
amazing beautiful invigorating parts of
america but i saw some dark parts of
america
an ugly side of america a side of
america that rarely sees the light of
day
i refer of course to the aims and
testicles of my co-star ken division
[Applause]
tonight has been an amazing night for
the both of us yes it has getting to
perform on stage at radio city
meeting janet jackson eminem
anyway
oh
this is fun two words come to mind life
insurance yes
girls girls just a reminder it's not how
big the banana is it's how you sit on it
what i'm sitting on a banana come on and
the golden globe goes too you want to
open it you want me to do it yeah i have
the nails yeah get after it
you got the globes too um
billy bob forden fargo
our gymnastics team was so dominant that
kevin durant told me he wants to play
for them next year
and now
back to
this [ __ ] that had a lot to say about
me the other day in the press miley
what's good
hey
we're all in this industry we all do
interviews and we all know how they
manipulate [ __ ] nikki congratulations
we're uh we're here tonight to present
the award for outstanding supporting
actor and actress in a comedy series we
used to submit ourselves in this
category but it didn't work out too well
for us
none of us ever won
well
i i won
yeah for
seriously for for our show or
yeah
well
how come you never told us
i i i guess i i just wanted to avoid
something awkward
huh like right now oh you know it's
funny because i i saw that emmy statue
of your house but i figured you just
ripped it off from some of the frasier
people
no
taylor
i i'm really happy for you i'm let you
finish but beyonce had one of the best
videos of all time
one of the best videos of all time
are going to be people along the way who
will try to undercut your success
or take credit
for your accomplishments or your fame
you'll look around and you will know
that it was you and the people who love
you who put you there and that will be
the greatest feeling in the world
[Music]
[Music]
the nominations for best actor and
supporting role are
that run on just threw me there
should be an olympic event shouldn't it
he could strap we hurdles to people and
get them me do that i would turn up
that was very pleasant i must say
geez we should do that motor much much
more often
no
and what a nice dress
[Applause]
first i'd like to thank um
could you lift that up please
[Laughter]
spin down first i'd like to thank
[Applause]
said eddie pull it up like i was working
for him
and i started to do it too yes mike wait
what am i doing and the golden globe
goes to
[Applause]
ben affleck argo
uh
what was this award for i'm sorry
huh
[Music]
oh oh
viewers choice oh my god y'all thank you
i am george clooney this is mark
wahlberg
we are uh here to present the award for
best uh villain
come on come here no no come on you're
in the middle you're in the middle just
get a little hit of clooney okay
i think we'll go right to the nominees
it doesn't get any better than that
really